benjamin locatelli et graffeurs évitons
suisse ce jour là nouriel et thibault
sont venus le film et l'interrogé sur
son métier pour ensuite intégrer la
vidéo dans le jeu qu'ils ont créés via
une application appelée onyx paix est
destiné aux jeunes qui s'interrogent sur
leur avenir
l'objectif de nick ce pc ca favoriser la
mixité l'ouverture d'esprit se dire eh
bien je peux être fait pour ce métier
aussi
donc on oblige à la découverte on oblige
à la rencontre parce que on ne sait
jamais à quel moment on va pouvoir
croiser le chemin ne mettiez finalement
la suite du travail se fait à belfort
c'est là que l'entreprise est née à
l'automne 2010 8
c'est là que tibou va mettre en forme
les images qu'il a ramené de suisse un
module photo et trois vidéos très
courtes pour dire aux jeunes ce qu'est
le métier de graffeurs et par quels
chemins on y arrive sur 45 secondes
expliquer l'essence d'un métier c'est
très court mais pour eux ça leur
correspond sur sur tout les tests qu'on
a pu faire c'est des formats qui qui
leur conviennent qu'il aura qui leur
plaisent et ça ça leur suffit pour
susciter une vocation
[Musique]
ça partait d'un constat très simple et
très clair c'est que j'avais le
sentiment que les jeunes étaient tenus
éloignés du monde de l'entreprise et que
les entreprises étaient tenus éloignés
du monde des jeunes car les entreprises
sont elles aussi partie prenante de
l'aventuré partenaires donnent xbl
apparaissent dans des univers que le
joueur va explorer exemple avec
l'industrie la zone est incontournable
c'est un peu notre univers industriel
eau etc
où est donc parle des rouages ou alors
des machines industrielles qui sont en
train de tourner avec différents
personnages avec lesquels on pourra
interagir afin de déclencher des
épisodes métier là c'est le métier de
d'automaticien chez edf d'accord donc
quelqu'un qui va refaire une suite
d'actions pour résoudre un problème
par exemple j'ai un gène portier godet
je dois arriver à trouver le le code
donc en regardant le plan il ya une
certaine logique qui se dégage donc wg
behe donc là par exemple exactement ce
sont des compétences griffith en clair
en jouant vous remplissez votre cv et
les entreprises intéressées par votre
profil peuvent demander à vous contacter
d'autant que l'application correspond à
des postes existants
on a vraiment sûr du cousu main un
épisode métier c'est la réalité d'une
entreprise sa réalité actuelle et puis
c'est ce qu'on cherche à transmettre
dans nos épisodes métier découvrir à la
fois sa vocation est l'entreprise qui va
avec c'est tout simplement ce qui est
arrivé à la jeune graphiste en stage
chez onyx p
[Musique]
par l'application donc j'ai été prise
dans l'univers et j'ai pu donc regarder
les épisodes métier donc notamment des
milliers de développeurs et donc deux
graphistes et c'est donc grâce à
l'application que j'ai compris que
vraiment c'est métier me correspondait
tout à fait en particulier donc celui du
graphiste vraiment donnés dans des
détails dans des anecdotes que je me
suis vraiment reconnue dans ce métier je
me suis dit ah oui marie vraiment c'est
ça que tu dois faire ces sacs tél vous
auriez aimé avoir une appli comme ça
quand vous avez cherché ce que vous
pouvez faire dans la vie mais c'est déjà
ça m'aurait but est de faire des études
en mécanique auto avant de devenir
directeur artistique sur un projet comme
ça et comme il n'est jamais trop tard
pour trouver sa voie l'application est à
télécharger gratuitement
[Musique]